next data stream for bigquery and a call
for your AI and ml questions next 2023
is still a few months away but be sure
to register before the end of May in
order to lock in early bird discount
pricing and stay tuned for how to join
us digitally data stream for bigquery is
now generally available offering a
seamless and easy to use experience that
enables near real-time insights and you
can check it out today we want to hear
from you about the AI and ml topics that
have you the most curious tell us your
questions in the comments below so we
can create our new series with the
answers that you're looking for get more
on all these stories at the links below
thanks for watching this episode of
Google Cloud update